hello welcome to the lobby gamespot's
weekly hang at every tuesday at two p.m.
pacific right here on gamespot com look
at these new cameras look at this new
set these people wearing purple yeah
purple kool kids klub day oh my god you
didn't get the memo did not conor
mcgregor's fighting this weekend so i
went with tim schafer's favorite shirt
he sent me a Christmas card last year to
Donnie on his shirt cuz wow that's
really noble yeah hard I'm bringing up i
can stop other words here alexa ray
korea's here aleppo and the internets I
don't know what to say you're from
you're from the internet now yeah I live
on the Internet Anthony Carboni how you
doing I sleep in the wired yeah yeah I'm
good man thanks for having me you're in
san francisco for PlayStation experience
came in for PlayStation experience yeah
that was fun that was good times yeah
just spend most of the weekend there
spent all weekend there yeah I was doing
the live stream it was me and Meredith
molinari and the PlayStation Blog crew
so Sid and Ryan Justin lots of stuff
kept you busy yeah dude for sure you're
busy launching your own thing as well i
am i am i have a patreon coming out
today live today half-finished but live
today and stairs finishing I'm like but
yeah you know I used to work for
discovery digital and helped create
rev3games and dnews and like a bunch of
those networks and over the last year I
haven't been doing as much of that stuff
and so now I want to get back to doing
weekly videos so like you know those
weird videos that I did earlier this
year about sort of the intersection of
science and games and like all that
stuff I want to do that stuff regularly
so have it all up on patreon.com /a
carboni and there's very little there to
tell you what's going on just yet but
it'll be up soon if you watch it might
just be there yeah I remember growing up
our of the growing up it's not like it
was that long ago everybody being back
in Europe being back in ireland and
london watching by jacker and really
enjoying it you know thanks man it's
just thinking it's kind of weird like
that was a show about like this this
grassroots new type of video game yeah
Woody's yeah like 2008 we were just like
there are these indie games you don't
have to buy them in a store and they're
done by small teams you'll never believe
it they're crazy some of them aren't
[ __ ] and now it's you go to something
like PSX or even III and it's like
seventy to eighty percent indie titles
for a lot of companies and you're like
alright it's cool so I would love to I
would love to start covering that stuff
again too you know let's talk about
PlayStation experience sure I was just
on over the weekend we were all there
the playing whatever games we could
playing Triple A game is playing indie
games and let's go down to catch Alexa
first of all what were some of the games
that sort of stood out to you at PSX uh
res okay I'm impress on the VR I don't I
get motion sick so I don't play your
games I played it with the Morpheus and
I didn't get sick I'm really really
happy so it's like I know you had a very
interesting read for arian so there was
a back room I think he wore this to I
tried to get in yeah okay and they were
like it's book text really you want to
wear the Tron's vibrator soosh you got a
book ahead yeah so mizoguchi being the
crazy person that he is built a suit
with 26 different vibrators on it and
you went in and played resin VR with the
suit vibrating in time to everything
that's happening and he was secretly
taking video of me while I was in the I
couldn't see or hear anything and it's
him just dancing up on me and it's up on
my Twitter it's hilarious it's just
mizoguchi just like yeah you like that
res you enjoy was he doing it to
everyone but you're the only one that's
got like evidence I think I'm one of the
few people that has evidence of him
doing it but I think he did it for a
couple other people yeah I liked her
with the end of this presentation he
just pulled the mask off and I got oh
look it's it's the maze and he's like
waves then it just shuts off yeah like
just I'm gone um I'm going yeah rah you
just saw that right okay I'm out enjoy
what I love about it what I love about
it is it lends itself so well like you
were saying to be our in terms of motion
sickness everything because of the
aesthetic of it you know when you're in
these like hyper realistic world or you
play something like a drive club because
they had driveclub there as well that
really sets off your inner ear and your
sense of balance and your sense of oh
this isn't real yeah you know what I
mean with something like res or super
hyper cube because of the aesthetic of
it and the feeling of openness and also
I think because its third person and VR
yeah I think that's it it makes you a
little less sick yeah but it's going
step removed in a way yes well we'll get
into the viewer stuff in a little while
as some of the other sort of big-name
games that we saw a game that I didn't
play for a while but I got
demonstration of and so did you as well
and media molecules dreams really what
do you think of it it's really
interesting I mean it's the next logical
progression of what they were already
trying to do with little big planet the
big planet to focusing very much on
creation creation tools empowering
players to sort of make their own
experiences although in talking to the
developers they told me that there will
be sort of a campaign of sorts a lot of
you know created content that exists
with you know sort of beginning and the
same way there was a little big planet
but it's kind of there to teach you how
to use the tools rather it definitely
seems that way yeah and that part was
not on display they were mainly showing
off the creation tools but they you know
we're explaining that you know this will
exist but there was really adamant that
everything in the the sort of campaign
portion of the game will be created with
the same tools that they're given to
players it's not like they're doing
something on there and with you know
their coding and specific stuff there
they're using the exact same tools
they're giving everyone else to create
their own campaign so in theory you
could create something just as robust or
detailed or rich or even story driven as
what they intend to create its employers
it's funny cuz that's like that's such a
fascinating thing and every time they
demo it they've been doing like these
regular dev streams every time they demo
it they create something completely
different with it and I think it's sort
of helping their cause and hurting their
cause in a way because it's hard to pin
down and explain to somebody within 30
seconds what dreams is and why you need
it and why you want it i think it's it's
very fascinating to people who are
artists or creators like they
immediately are like oh i just want to
touch this thing and who's this thing
but like when you're explain to somebody
who wants to play a game like what do I
do with dreams yeah how do I use it what
am I doing with this thing they're like
whatever you want it's like I don't it's
almost like they need a tool I'm not a
game it kind of feels like that they've
been an application development for the
past couple years because they they've
made this tool soon and I was really
taken aback by how enjoyable the process
of making actually seemed to be like
yeah it's like looking at Bob look at
many people watch bob ross on Twitter
painting I could watch somebody use this
who's like good at using it oh yeah that
seems comparison actually to them when i
was talking to them and they were
explaining how they wanted to make it
accessible and wanted everyone to feel
like they were creating something
worthwhile and i feel like they were
failing to create and in talking about
that it did make me think of bob ross
and sort of his
painting and and they said yeah
absolutely they agreed that that was a
good analogy for what they're sort of
trying to do and then they also we're
fully open about yeah this is really
about creation I mean it's not a
traditional game like we're used to
seeing it's not like oh I can pick this
up and you know play six hours and I've
done it's it is more of a creation
system and one thing that's thought was
really fascinating that they pointed out
is you're going to be able to save
whatever you create as a 3d image file
and then print it on a 3d printer yeah
or you can make characters in the game
this thing is too crazy 3d print as long
as you've accessed so you can be you
want to point them into dreams that's
just like a toy creation system and like
I just want to create a thing I could
put on my desk that's great it's not a
game it's a toy creation tool fine
that's that's how you wanted a you stand
out because like 3d modeling is
essentially standardized you can also
like import this stuff into Maya if you
want it yeah like it's all alike yes
they were saying that it is sharing and
letting people like if you just want to
be a character creator you can do that
and then other people can take what you
create put it in their own games or
print it for themselves and so it really
is about empowering players to create
and not so much acting as a traditional
video game so if you want to think of it
as a creation tool system and I think
that's a perfectly valid perspective on
one dreams actually is although again
yeah that is not super easy to
communicate gatley or easily or sexy
it's weird i was i was super cold on was
until I saw them doing that stuff and it
didn't say anything we can do is super
cool like the level of the customers
customization and just things you can do
it's it's incredible the detail that you
can put into things it looks like they
really took that sort of the search mech
like I remember when you were able to
search in Little Big Planet 3 for like
everything then the search system was so
good and they really applied that to
dreams in an interesting way when they
were doing the on-stage dem weather like
I'm making a monster but I don't like
drawing eyes i'm bad at eyes so i'm
gonna look up eyes I don't see all the
odds and here's a guy who makes nothing
but eyes and here's a guy who lists
himself as a guy who makes nothing but
monster puns and so you can like mix and
match from all these people who already
do amazing things it's interesting
because it's going to be it's going to
live and die based on this community and
what it winds up being whether it winds
up being a game or a creation tool or
whatever is going to be totally
dependent on what the highest number
of people is doing with it right which
is I think is also interesting yeah
because you see merrymaker go one way
where it's like oh the first couple
weeks it's all these automatic levels
and it was in this other direction yeah
it's gonna be super interesting yeah
from mario maker though and arguably
word for from minecraft as well and in
littlebigplanet simat i think that there
are third space or something exists to
succeed although you're very right that
it is very dependent on what the
community does with it and that will
dictate how the experience of all
stepping away from that we've got a
bunch of games to cover uncharted 4 as
well among things we saw you now it's a
telltale love trees yeah I want to know
how that impacts things like I love the
idea I'm all about dialogue trees in
love telltale I loved you know like the
day sex game its mascot all accounts um
but I want to know like if it has a
tangible impact on games like as you
know this is new to get a row k so this
dialog choice right here is the one that
they showed off and you're right it's
kind of like wait Charlie did you like
the best yeah how's that gonna change
things yeah yeah I think they were just
kind of showing off like hey this is in
there now without showing off so i need
to know more like how is impacted the
game and the way that narratives can be
like if it's Dawson's that's fine right
yeah like if it's just something to keep
you engaged a cutscene it I don't know
it's just feel strange if it's not gonna
have a broader in that John I just I
want to know more it can be one of those
things that where it's subtle you know
where it's one of those deals where it
doesn't look like because uh you know
David cages stuff is kind of like that
too where you make a choice and it
doesn't feel like it's affected anything
but then if you go back and you play
again you're like oh that was really
subtle when it changed telltale does
that really well sometimes too I like
that it's nathan drake like notary
public or importer exporter or something
yeah just like filling out papers and
he's just like grumbling it was a great
choice narrative choice on the the
writers partner because I mean we are so
used to seeing Nathan doing like these
spectacular things and dangling off a
train you know is we're so used to
seeing with precarious positions that
putting him in the most mundane setting
a possible is just really jarring he's a
family man clever that was very Oliver
and their mark sets the stage for it's
such a good like rubber banding of the
conflict that has always been between
Nate and Elena too yeah where it's just
kind of like do just like slow your roll
for five minutes and then like okay
maybe he finally does for a few years
and let's see what that's done to their
marriage
and then he's late for dinner because
he's talking to his brother on it was
like family slowed him down with
anything that's going way but oh I love
that he was like oh wait I'm married
like that's such a bunch of Nate Drake
line to he's like oh yeah by the way
I've got this wife she hangs out
sometimes and screams at me not to jump
into pirate ships we also got to see a
bunch we also got to see a bunch more of
a far cry primal as well ya see my
comments earlier highly playable and we
know what it is yeah yeah was it
playable there yeah yeah yeah I had a
bunch of kiosks set up I think it's uh
the gameplay videos that people have
been seeing on on gamespot and other
sites that's the same portion that was
playable and shop floor but yeah just a
quick taste of like it just drops you
into the world and says okay go kill
some stuff it'll be fun and I jumped on
a woolly mammoth writing that around
right argit stuff and yeah means it's
you're gonna beast master and you can
ride something and if you won't let you
ride it you can kill it and if you and
if somewhere in between somewhere in
between right there for you yeah that's
so when I was talking to Jas about it
you know he's that he's the narrative
designer of it I love that they're kind
of like stripping away more and more of
the things that I feel like sort of got
in my way and far cry and getting to the
things that I really love so like far
cry 3 you think about like oh I want
that bear to eat those dudes but in
order for that bear to eat those dudes
I've got to like unlock the thing and
like throw some whatever and like yeah
and really make it happen in this one
it's just kind of like yo bear yeah all
I want to see is a bear kill a bunch of
dudes can we make this happen yeah you
can be friends with the honey badger now
that all there's like 17 different
animals I like that you do kind of like
a oh and a giant prehistoric death owl
comes down it's really insanely large
yeah it's like did you use it till I
kill anybody you can utter it walk it
will destroy people it's a brutal
ambitions and you can upgrade it to
throw like poison bombs to bomb morale
because Y is really they're really
making it just everything I want out of
a far cry he was showing me a part where
they go to where he's hunting you know
he's hunting an animal and as he's about
to shoot it just like an eagle randomly
comes down and takes the animal and he's
like I guess I don't get that animal I'm
like what just happened he's like
Eagle a tit man I'm like hi is life with
the priests yeah he's like this is the
way it is I'm just this is gonna be so
good did it feel like a sort of a Blood
Dragon II sized game or does it like
it's hard to tell on those types of that
yeah I think they're looking to make it
as big as you know as big as for was the
biggest three was and you know other
things that they streamline to he said
no radio towers nothing like that you
walk you what's gonna happen people
gonna be like [ __ ] mist i miss the
radio tower hey i'm just walking around
it's got elements I'm just walking
around unlocking the map as I go this is
stupid where the radio towers now no
one's ever gonna say that Danny well no
I will really shake radio tower fan
anything else which is any indie games
any big stuff oh sure I mean like fire
wash still looks at me yeah we'll see
plenty of her watch that's go radio
tower that does over radio tower they're
not vomiting captors very proudly to the
nearest it does game looks good I like
that it's sort of realistic but not like
the the animation style is very cartoony
like that you're playing as like really
needy hands needy cartoon hands Alex
yeah it's beautiful and it just gets
more and more beautiful every time I see
it and which is great because it has
that same basic cartoony style but every
time I go back it's just like a little
more layered a little more beautiful we
still have very little idea what it
actually is that's fine whatever I guess
we'll know soon it seems like kind of
like a couple of steps up from what
we've seen of the you know to be
reductive that walking simulator genre
this you know this one feels like you've
a little bit more agency but it's not it
doesn't feel like a big world to do lots
of yeah zanuck like somewhere in the
middle it kind of feels like yeah you
have a lot like there's an instance I
know the one that we've seen over and
over and over is the one with the boom
box where ya either throw the boom box
in the lake or like take it and like
yell at them or whatnot but I was
talking to Sean manaman when I went to
play and it sounds like um it sounds
like there will be a lot of choices like
that and what you do will sort of
influence like how like the area okay or
maybe like how like people react you or
how like Delilah talks to you like yeah
yeah yeah and by the way of showing
manaman sounds familiar but people are
totally sure we're watching dad's the
guy who wrote season one of the walking
dead for telltale so that's you know
gives me a lot of abandoned what this
project could could they got they got
Nels Anderson on
he was a guy clay who made mark of the
ninja so yeah they got it's a team that
knows their stuff yeah Boone yeah let's
talk about the showstopper of the press
conference Paragon yeah Oregon I darragh
I know it's like it ended the show it
was sort of them felt like a whimper it
was like oh that's it its core to movin
okay I don't know fair enough it's you
can go play it now I think using your
grill Engine launcher or yeah yeah
there's like an alpha there's alpha
access right now I don't know if that's
like limited access or everybody's open
I don't know how that's working it's
very interesting to me it's very
interesting to me it's sort of the same
way like what is it dungeon defenders
like Dungeon Defenders is basically
tower defense yes but because they are
switching up the perspective into more
of a first-person action perspective I
enjoy dungeon defenders more than I
enjoy a tower defense game and I think
that's what they're looking to try to do
with MOBAs because I think MOBAs are
sort of shrouded in this layer of sort
of jargon and you know people who are
really into them it's a very like
insular community but I think when you
watch a mobo you're kind of like I get
the basic idea of what's going on like I
understand the lands I understand that
we're both trying to get to like this
other side I get it but there are all
these things that kind of complicate and
remove I think most people from MOBAs
everything from you know that community
that I was talking about to the
perspective like the top down click only
perspective feels like one of like a
strategy game yeah exactly so I think
they're trying to do like no this is a
really fun type of game this is an
amazing game four teams of people for
four groups of friends so let's see if
we can make that accessible and fun and
awesome looking okay let's give it a
shot after playing over Washington
joying it so much yeah that's the game
that really broke me out of oh this is
straight-up a first-person MOBA and it's
probably the best first-person game i
played this year me like I adore
overwatch yeah hopefully ever cracking
that not and you know the MOBA which is
quite reductive it may be expanding into
other things and moving a bit long on
this any other shed its two games you
guys play that you want to make sure you
mention shoutouts to video games
Eva thinks enjoy them video games all oh
yeah actually very cool really huge
change yep bound looked amazing
battleborn continues to like actually
seem like a pretty cool game even though
no sinks all that interested in it uh
little game called Klaus that was really
good headliners really good matt Lanter
is amazing there's a page of your stuff
which we're gonna talk about yeah second
actually so Oh kind of cool stuff at
ease I wish we could just like Radloff a
tenant you know today names but if you
want more PSX go to gamespot com we got
all that stuff right there who's right
in a second to talk about virtuality
games ever let us know what you think
are some of the games that you as a
viewer in the internet were found and
entertaining and inspiring and
PlayStation experience this year we've
been back in just a second first of all
here's a trailer for game the Kim add-on
early access I feel like Gandhi barons
been playing this for about six months i
think it's officially out now it's dirt
rally no
is leaning no yahoo is leaving yell so
his name
is leaving yeah
virtual reality is coming whether you
like it or not internet PlayStation
virtual reality ain't no Morpheus no
more and our title here are you gonna be
taking Alexa he'll cross your other leg
of virtual reality cross your leg the
other way there we go cheers across now
we're killing it now we're killing it
playstation vr PlayStation VR we've been
talking about vr4 feels like eons yeah a
couple years at least but we're sort of
on the it's on the horizon everyone's on
the hook now everyone's kind of thrown
down like this is when we're releasing
our thing so we're getting real close
yeah I'm getting excited we don't have a
price yet but I think we're at the stage
our people are kind of deciding whether
or not they're going to be picking up a
virtual reality headset and with
PlayStation experience and sort of
seeing all the games that they were old
hours I think a lot people are you know
PlayStation 4 owners are thinking Oh am
I gonna be putting money aside for a
couple of months and picking up one of
these PlayStation of yours and let's
talk about some of the games that we saw
as shown first of all I'm at the at the
conference at Peter what were some of
the ones that jumped out to me res was
by far the most interesting way I need
to beat a dead horse but as someone who
loved the Dreamcast and loved res in
particular and loves eval curry I see a
lot of the things in you Valkyrie
mimicked in res infinite which is like
using you know the direction that you're
looking to sort of aim the reticle and
that's perfect it works so well it's
nice one to one and that's the sort of
thing you want in virtual reality you
want it to mimic what you're doing in
real life now maybe I'm not flying
through a simulated computer space thing
filled neon colors but I can at least
feel like I am when I'm inning in that
direction yeah I love that and I love
that they give that they give you the
flexibility within it because some
people were using just the head for the
radical I was using the right stick
because that's what I'm used to and they
both worked equally well and what's
great is they they work together in
tandem in a really interesting way to so
if I'm like trying to lock on and then I
do one of those things like I did in the
old res where I look over in the corner
of my own I'm just like oh no I forgot
to lock on to that guy just by looking
over to him I've locked on right and so
it makes the whole thing just like it's
much quicker much easier you Valkyrie
does that same thing you need to use it
to like lock onto ships so if you're
flying forward you the ship goes by you
like hold on I'm
walk on gotcha yeah it's just sort of
like you know that analog gap to what
you would do and and it's brilliant I
mean that that aesthetic like I keep
saying it's it's such a simple aesthetic
which works wonderfully in VR everybody
wants to build this crazy realistic city
that you can walk around yeah this
hardware is just not there yet early vr
is gonna be all about good art direction
and that something res has always has it
looks like it has an aged day when you
look at it there's something about that
design aesthetic that means a Gucci put
into it that's just like brilliant and
fresh today the same way it was in 2001
well because it's interesting because
you know we're so used to seeing these
121 like one of the biggest problems of
yours like how do you move around and
you get people to move around if they
can't move around in their space do we
have it sodas there's a controller or do
we have it so they know you lean forward
and you can move around spaces that way
yeah where's like actually you can make
lots of different for your experiences
that aren't 121 matches with you being
in a human body well that's something
that Tim Schaefer was talking about
because you know psychonauts VR the
rhombus of ruin was one of the big
announcements and he was talking about
how it will not be a traditional game
where you're where you're moving around
it's going to use razzes psychic powers
and like maybe you're jumping from one
person's head to another and that's how
you get around they're gonna fall back
on their adventure game pedigree and
make it very much dialogue based in
story base and I think that's gonna work
so wonderfully it's inching about LexA
you were talking earlier about how like
you tend to not try a lot of yer because
you get motion sick but you didn't
really enough with res which kind of
feels like a game that is throwing you
around quite a lot so I've never I've
never tried the Morpheus before on my
last PlayStation VR edition PR and my
last experience was maybe almost two
years ago I played like an oculus at an
event and got i thinkI Valkyries right
you just got finally out like I get
motion sick from first-person shooters
if I'm not careful ever seen cloverfield
that movie made me but yes then you're
gonna love Cloverfield VR but I plate so
I played Reds and I don't know if it's
because maybe it wasn't like it oh here
are my hands here is my body and I'm
just doing it but I actually got really
brave and did that I did the head
tracking and I used
the head and at one point there was like
a lull in the music and I looked down
and it's just the tracks going by me and
it's like a little disorienting but I
didn't get sick and I'm very excited now
because maybe it's like I don't know if
it's like res in particular or the fact
that its third person or the fact that
the Morpheus is like the more [ __ ] the
PlayStation Vita yeah i'm just not and
is and I don't feel disoriented I don't
know if it's that or but I feel like a
whole new world has been opened up to me
now I've been avoiding it for so long
this works it's strange with so much of
what we've seen it seems like they're
figuring attacks yeah like you over the
pasta tutors in or longer we've seen
like iterations on this technology and
it feels like for usability sake and
also like the types of games were saying
like it's all sort of clicking into
place yeah what I've noticed what I've
noticed and I just kind of clicked with
me now after hearing Alexis say this is
the things that are working the best for
me are things where you're either some
sort of body or object free-floating or
you're locked to one space like in job
simulator where ya at a desk because you
kind of get around that whole like why
does it look like I'm walking but I'm
not walking why does my body want to
vomit more than anything ever in the
world right now I had so much fun with
job simulator like it obviously you know
type of experience it probably isn't too
much fun to play over and over and over
again but like just the you know I
wonder will this work and then it works
like I picked up the plant and put in
the coffee machine and it I found this
disc and I put it into the computer and
ended up being like a flappy bird clones
got loaded on it's kind of like surgeon
signal of your idiot baby hands just
like mashing on the keyboard there
there's some fun oh it's married owner
oh it's Mary's idiot baby but then on
the other side good Mary is what i meant
to say I pinch I there you go there's
the idiot baby i'm i'm on the other side
of that room i play driveclub and I I
played it and I've done of the racing
games of your I'm actually that kind of
felt like it didn't really work I kind
of felt like it was well you don't need
which is the thing everybody thinks that
racing is going to be like the perfect
natural fit and it sort of is but it's
also the thing that needs VR the least
rice because I sort of always looking
forward keeping your eye on the track
and what's going on and so it was very
rare
actually used any head tracking it yeah
clap like in most racing disciplines
you're like even your wind mirrors are
like within you know I flicking layer
you know I guess of why you're split
your I folk impressive thing about the
drive club demo was they were showing
off how far the PlayStation VR headset
has come since that initial prototype
right the same way they're showing off
the how far the oculus has come and
things like that as their you know
raising these frame rates and these
refresh rates and everything is getting
brighter and the head tracking is
getting more one-to-one they're just
trying to show off like hey we can do an
experience like this now and it will not
make alexa ray corriea vomit much it's
comfortable too isn't it like that unit
Peter you I feel like of all the people
at gamespot your views view or the most
and you're the most experienced we're
using all the different iterations of
these how do you think that PlayStation
view our headset feels cuz to me it's
like it's so light it feels super easy
to like move on your head and everything
yeah I mean as these things develop you
know obviously the materials get refined
they realize they don't need as much
circuit board they can they can find
lighter materials that wick away
moisture and stuff and these things
become more comfortable and I think some
people will always find something to
complain about but really yeah like the
Morpheus is really comfortable Nowak
euless it is really comfortable even the
latest gear VR I mean people are
iterating on these pretty quickly and
coming up with solutions discuss max for
demo those poor guys that's the bomb
there it is of that was not uh this is
that did not go well for them and you
know if you look at how fast it's
progressed already over the past three
years project 10 years down the road
right right I mean these things will
continue to shrink continue to be more
comfortable we are at like the the
frontier of VR even now still after
years of doing this stuff it hasn't hit
market really like it'sit's not really
gone mainstream and gotten the money to
keep making more things and keep
refining it so it's just going to get
smaller and more comfortable so unit
it's not perfect right now don't
discount it like the some of the early
experiences are great and they totally
make up for a little bit of discomfort
because you get an experience unlike
anything you've played on a traditional
TV with a cup of control I think that's
a great point I think if it can make it
through these first three or four years
if these companies can really like stick
it out keep supporting it don't pull
money out of it to say the way they
pulled money out of like
connect or a move or something like that
as long as they don't get bored and see
the prophets kind of not coming in for
the first three or four years I think
this is something that could really
catch on but it's something where
they're going to have to commit to
backing well the thing is that most
people now at least in our groups right
we talk about this as a game first
device but the R is being utilized and I
guess I've said this a lot of times I
feel like I'm repeating myself but it's
used for therapy yeah a lot like burn
victims heal fast you're walking through
snow when EVR you know PTSD people are
able to overcome these memories that
haunt them by reliving them in a
different content so those are the sort
of things and even like airlines like
putting VR in the seats those are the
sort of things that are going to support
the new yarn yeah games will it benefit
as a result yeah I would be shocked if
it didn't continue down the road it's
already going I mean you see somebody
like Samsung jump in bed with with
oculus and you know and then Facebook
owning oculus like those are two big
powerhouses they are not going to just
get their toes wet and sure well it's
cold they're gonna jump in you know full
force and will continue to do so well I
think that's interesting because then
that brings up like Sony I mean Sony
obviously is thinking about this in
terms of movies entertainment and games
but they're sort of they're not on the
forefront of like those same sort of
things that you're talking about with
these research companies where it's like
well they don't really put money into
things like therapies and that source of
so there may be the company that has the
most to lose but also I think has the
best chance of getting a toehold in the
consumer market because I'm not going to
have to have a high end pc to the box is
already in my living room these games
already run to spec without me having to
fiddle with anything the way you have to
with an oculus or anything right now so
they have the they have a big chance to
kind of take the living room which i
think is interesting and you can really
see from the like all their PSX
presentations that they really want the
living room they want it so bad right
now cheers to see diversity for that
living room curious to see what valve
does know that they've started their
whole steam machine initiative although
it's not taken off very well you know
how far are they from having a box that
they sanction is being this is the you
know the valve vr box yeah right and
that'll sort of get rid of all the
hi npc stuff because really developers
just have to aim for a certain spec like
they're doing you know as you described
at the PlayStation 4 so I could see you
know HTC cornering the pc market where
the valves help down the road I mean
that could be happening that works out
really well for them looking for gamers
in general i love that we're talking
about all this only all these lofty
technology goals and everything like
that and all i want to do is play 100
foot robot golf with ya so like we talk
about when we talk about this as we
start projecting like you know five or
ten years in the future and it feels
like there's so much like not optimism
but people are fighting for VR in a way
that they didn't we connect and move
like pina or even seems like more and
more people are sort of they wanted to
work so like sort of Real Talk 2016
PlayStation VR comes out I know where
maybe though it's skewed a little bit
because we're people who do this
professionally but like how who's going
to buy one like Alexa are you going to
get when he said it didn't make me barf
so probably hmm I'd like to that's
actually the top of your scale yeah
first scale goes her scale goes from
fainting and vomiting to didn't make me
barf it didn't make me part I'm excited
about that because everyone's talking
about the yard yeah you all you guys all
come back from shows and it's like oh I
played this Ike like that and I'm like
oh so that's not like you didn't want to
be left out of that conversation so I
wonder if there's gonna be enough people
who buy this who then you know that
early adopter thing where they're like
push everyone else in Tulsa I'm gonna
have three headsets in my house by the
end of Max you really think you it
really am going to have three headsets
in my house I am an idiot I will do it I
love it that well you don't know which
one pornhub is gonna go with right don't
till I know yeah until because I want to
play robot golf but i also want to get
up on that robot something else
yesterday razor was they have their own
open source VR headset okay CEO of razor
tweeted out and i'm not saying we're
supporting porn out of the box but i am
saying there is a native app for the
only view our porn producer out there
Wow on arc device out of the bar
headsets Danny out of the bar I'm going
to have
Peter I'm assuming you'll probably jump
in on a bunch of them yeah I mean I'm
yes I think I even though I am like
really passionate about it i will
probably go for the easiest solution
first hmm um samsung gear vr is great
but i don't really like Samsung phones
alright so for me it will probably be
PlayStation VR I have a ps4 I like some
of the demos that they've put out I will
have a rift in time but in time is the
key word so do you think that
playstation 4 winners are going to pick
this up because by the time this comes
out we will be two and a half in coming
up to three years after a console as
come out maybe that takes the sting out
of having to spend whatever it is they
ask act like its people are ready for
the next best thing and it's not gonna
come for another seven years right right
yeah why wouldn't it's all gonna be
about price point though I think it's
all gonna be about price point the
camera do sit for less than like three
hundred writers know they could they
could easily subsidize it oh right yeah
you think I think so but would they
that's the big question you think so I
think they will have to get people to
anybody this is really going to catch
fire is if people are at their friend's
house and using it right so Sony can't
get this into people's hands right it's
not they're not gonna be able to market
it so well with a commercial it's going
to be experiencing it because I've
talked to people about VR a thousand
times and it's not until like you tried
that demo again yeah that you were like
oh wow okay and me and Andy baman went
into that room the the the sort of VO
room that they had for the price and
he's kind of like he gets hot and cold
on the sort of stuff and when he put the
headset on he came over and went you
know I like we watch videos of people
like playing VR all the time like this
stuff he's like we're just gonna shoot
more b-roll of this stuff and it doesn't
really put it across he was like I put
the headset on I was like oh yeah sorry
I remember this is [ __ ] amazing but
you know the big the big thing that
really made me go all in at PSX was
we're finally seeing games yet seeing a
lot of demos of like pick up a thing and
you're in a forest and look around and
it's like no this is a game and a lot of
them yeah like it feels like there's now
I'm at the stage where I can't name all
the VR games that are coming out on on
Playstations thought form and that's
important because I think people were
seeing it as this long-term tech demo
now it's kind of like oh yes 100-foot
robot golf I get
did you know you could pick up stuff and
put it in the photocopier and it made
duplicates I am like 15 Donuts by the
end of this game yeah do I really need
to work like that thank laura is [ __ ]
tea Earl Grey that's on him virtual
reality there you go I have four to four
thumbs up or you know maybe eight we can
go and here on the couch let us know
what you think of VR do you want to play
station 4 you're gonna pick up a
PlayStation VR yourself and what's the
right price point let us know in the
comments below we're almost done today
folks you know it was announced what was
also announced that PlayStation
experience I think you're gonna say
something that wasn't announced but was
was talk to bash more he's got all the
girls I was like there's that the quad
really don't know what you're talking
about I don't know what this we go back
to the pornhub thing no okay all right i
got that point up trailer ready Mary
here we go yak-yak who's a fine oh yeah
yeah remember yeah well it was a nice
long time all the girls are beautiful I
think that's what I said and we just a
bit weird about the announcement of the
office is 0 which is yeah yeah
previously all right well we don't have
the trailer for that we're shown we're
showing the trailer for ya who's a fight
already so what imagine it's yakka 0
yeah minus 5
gralen unnie up today
the Cardinals it'll work
Hopsin over ginger ale
not just as a remaster but as a remake
and over the weekend a PlayStation
experience we saw some more of that
remake Lex ray Korea Anton Carboni Peter
Brown who's excited for Final Fantasy
I'm gonna defer to the Final Fantasy
scholar here yeah we're 25 are you a
final fantasy scholar as well I would
say so I don't agree but I don't know
you the way I know Alexa training of
cool we saw a bunch of Midgar on for a
reason to see first 20 minutes of the
game and the first Dennis after a final
fantasy yeah yeah what's up episodic
content so subsequently I guess square
put out a press release that goes on
Sunday saying that part yeah the story
will be told across a multi-part series
with each entry providing its own unique
experience as Final Fantasy fans does
that ring alarm bells or does that sound
fine I so I go both ways I am so I am
NOT as Anthony is not the biggest fan of
final fantasy 7 okay it's a fine game
it's not the best one no but no I and
considering considering they've put out
the game and then they made this the
prequel the sequel the CGI movie the
spin a couple games that world has been
beaten into the ground and they've done
and they've just sort of it's all sort
of dried up to me but the fact that
we're gonna get Final Fantasy 7 in a
different way in a different format
piques my interest yes cool i like to
see you if you can make this a fresh
experience yeah i'll play it also the
final fantasy nerd so i will however my
worry with the episodic thing is is it
going to be something like what tail
tail does in which each episode or part
is self-contained because what happens
if say the first episode is all Midgar
and the second episode is pulling a
random whatever caused the canyon or
something if you want to go back and
complete the quests that you didn't or
do things that you didn't in Midgard
episode 1 can you go back to previous
content is it going to pile on top of
each other or will they be a
self-contained experiences because part
of what makes final fantasy so appealing
is that you have these vast worlds that
you can go back and do whatever do
whatever side quest when you want it and
a lot of people i know we were talking
about this earlier
after you do the story you spend the
next 20 hours grinding and cleaning up
everything else that you didn't do in
the game yeah can we do that here I
don't know I've played maybe I think the
first like three or four hours of final
fantasy seven only recently as well this
year so I'm not a scholar when it comes
to this peter is it the type of game as
well that you can sort of you can drift
forward into areas that you maybe
shouldn't early or does the story very
much sort of like unlock stuff its
there's a lot of side content that
people love even optional stuff like
getting Vincent or you fee for example
but Chuck Bob reading reading those oh
yeah get that gold chocobo golden saucer
wait what's your turn look you know I
think the fact that this is happening at
all is kind of a boon for people who
appreciate this game and while I would
love to have a faithfully recreated like
massive new version of Final Fantasy 7
i'm not kidding myself there's no way
Square Enix is going to do that
faithfully and one hundred percent but
if I can get really well-composed
vignettes that take me back to the game
that I really love and show it showcase
it in a new way and let me interact in
that world I'll be really happy now the
fact that they're charging a full price
per episode we don't know that yet okay
well the fact that it sounds like they
might be doing that anyway it is you
know that's concerning if it's something
like a telltale Game Wow like who can
complain at that point but when you say
vignettes that sort of Buckley no raises
alarm rings alarm bells am I can't tell
the difference looking at the two of
them side by side because that's like
that could mean that it's not the entire
game than I can say that this is just
like a you know three hour segments oh
you remember this cool part of a kind of
fantasy seven see here's the thing most
people never talk about Final Fantasy 7
and how it relates to today right so
many games in the series are so far like
out of the realm of possibilities i'm
not saying materia is a thing or that
chocobos are real but but what I know I
know as much but he's also not saying
chocobos aren't real right okay no no
furl you we're not we're not drawing a
conclusion on chocobos no my favorite
pokemon but this this game really at its
heart is about you know corporations
running a muck it is about exploiting
the environment it is about rebels
taking on forces that are insurmountable
the common man and doing so in a way
that's destructive but also
revolutionary and I think that those
themes are really powerful and you don't
need this stuff like chocobo racing to
do that and frankly eight but that is
one a five-point good thing though I
love final fantasy seven it is my
favorite game alongside tactics but at
the same time we still have the original
and we don't have them play in on
PlayStation 4 right now so if people
love as much as they say they do but
your money where your mouth isn't
playing you know but if if if we're
honest with ourselves we cannot expect
square to take a game that featured
pre-rendered backgrounds and create a
fully fleshed-out 3d world around it 121
for the price of one game no that's
totally I'm not doing that yeah they
said they're gonna try to keep as much
of the content in as possible they're
gonna cut some stuff but they said
they're also gonna be adding some stuff
so I get this feeling that they want
these episodes to be longer than just a
few hours I'm thinking they're thinking
you know maybe these are 20 hours apiece
maybe these are things that are worth
worth buying because it's the length of
an average game and I have to say if
somebody as a person sitting on the
couch who's not a fan of final fantasies
in it who like I get it it is the game
that built the PlayStation I understand
why it has such a huge place in so many
people's hearts I never liked the game
but watching this the way they're doing
the way they're doing it would be the
kingdom hearts / Final Fantasy 15 combat
the way they're kind of like making it
new and making it a more accessible game
in a way that doesn't seem to be taking
away from the aesthetic and the things
that fans love I'm a like this version
of Final Fantasy 7 this may wind up
being a net positive right because
everybody who loves final fantasy 7 gets
what they want and I get a final fantasy
7 and you get a final fantasy 7 that
maybe you make it past the first few
hours right you know maybe we all wind
up liking it a lot more and it kind of
takes this dried-up world that you're
talking about and makes it new again
superdry it's almost super dry it's like
it's like most thankless job in
development trying to make this game
because some people are going to want it
to evolve some people are going to want
it to be as true to form as possible
some people would be happy with the new
graphics and people want just an up res
version the purest remastering you could
possibly think of do you think that like
you guys have expressed sort of a bit
more you guys are okay with this
changing it up a bit you know too
a game play in terms of how it's
released all that sort of stuff do you
think the general final fantasy 5 20
years later is going to be as accepting
of those changes ah yes and no I know
there are a lot of people that are or
will be angry that this is that it's
episodic it's not they're not getting
final fantasy 7 remade a game they're
getting something in pieces and I I've
been on the internet I have seen the sad
um don't go on the internet time know
red is literally where all the saddest
there and there are people out there
that also like are like they love final
fantasy but won't play seven the
original cuz I think it looks bad they
don't want to waste their time with it
mhm um I think that the people that love
the game for what it is will play this
and be like I'm getting something I love
like Peter said again in a new way and
yeah but I also can definitely see
people being outraged about it
personally if someone who's like big fan
of the series again not a fan of seven
um I I i really like it I like give you
give me final fancy anything that
freakin like the chippy final fantasy
game world final fantasies coming out
next year and it looks like it looks
like a kids game I'm gonna play cuz its
final fantasy nerd that's a modest yeah
to get it um you know I can see this
both earning a lot of love but also so I
kind of losing a lot yeah well you guys
have had your say now it's up to the
Internet let us know what you think
final fantasy 7 remaster remake really
make Maori masters we made remake we
made we make meaning we make you got it
remain one of those is right Final
Fantasy 6 week last night you think you
excitedly disappointed put your thoughts
in the comment box below alright we're
almost done with a show but first we got
to give away some stuff I told you my
favorite Pokemon hey Chuck about all
right Chuck about yeah but what's your
favorite Pokemon at an x-ray career uh
squirtle ok Ashley carp OD a big Evie
fan Evie yeah I'm a big eyed soul I have
a holy I have a plumber in at home wow
that looks kind of like an EV that's
kind of why I got a Pomeranian yeah like
Evie and I like flareon that's guy I got
a pair of keys back home that looked
like a klefki mmhmm yeah look at
baguette trash that looks like at
rubbish chubby
hey Peter what's your favorite Pikachu
what's well piggeh 23 ratings probably
some sort Pikachu squirtle Finn just
named a polka our good friends at
Pokemon Center naw Kham sent us and two
of these we have to this is one set and
we're giving away two of them it's got a
bunch of trading cards it's got this is
an endo roid y'all this is the real deal
and then don't Lloyd my nindo roids are
illegal in some states and you can win
one of these packs here's an old trading
card game it's really heavy alright it's
put in your pocket okay missile my
microphone there's another one right
there yeah you can wait by heart on this
game is also a game of Thrones spoilers
hit that retweet yeah that's really good
no one heard that oh damn spot you
followed you for a chance to win retweet
courtesy of Pokemon Center thank you
finally the pokemon in Game of Thrones
crossover that everyone was asking for
telltale games here at el tio que si
would you play a telltale pokemon game
yes yeah I'll play a telltale anything I
got Batman coming out I'll play that
Batman oh god we didn't talk of any of
that yet no talk about what else to do
they did a couple more to do in one
nation three Walking Dead Season three
hey unannounced mart unannounced marvel
game okay but the announced but have not
named yet all right um and the Michonne
thing and Game of Thrones Season to the
Michonne thing I was out with that
walking dead season 3 1 is no she's
getting around games you get her own one
yeah Michelle Michelle I like it there
you go same a shaman Peter Michelle
there you go window roids are legit over
to achievement unlocked who is this
person I don't know who it is is a neat
from pokemon X&Y could be its n and
connect them all and one to change one's
experience I have the eye of the
nendoroid the winwaker link ok and metal
gear 5 snake with them oh yeah the
middle your 56 yeah I got the original
he looks like a baby yeah how much it
cost not that much like 70 80 bugs yeah
you can get it when you be worth up if
you find them on if you find it on
Amazon like by somebody who's who's like
importing tons of like I got my link for
50 okay yes panin buy it they're
starting to release of an American
Jaffer Wildcats japantown oh that is
that how it's in Japan yeah I've only
seen it written japen to me oh yeah if
it was in England they call it jabber
did you carboni thanks today and showing
us the pokemon cards and one more time
your patreon patreon it's Patrian it's
and we have it in [ __ ] n'ton it's a
patriot it's patreon.com /a Carboni the
pages half finished it will be totally
finished tonight but it's open and going
and doing the tanks awesome thanks to
the folks at Cena for allowing us to use
their beautiful studio look at all this
sick ass construction what's going on
outside that view is just fine you can
see the bay ones there was only a new
set right yeah that's the transbay
septic oh there were moments during this
when I was pretty sure just because of
the way the lens works on your single
that that crane was just gonna roll
right through your head Danny just right
through your skull and thanks everyone
production Mary kiss Josh Shaw we got
some senior folks in the back up on that
as well thank you and I'll know your
names but you're rad but she that Mike
guy said Udo I will be back next week we
got one more episode of the lobby from
up here this year we're taking a bit of
a break in January bullying back and
with that none all of our game of your
stuff which is currently ramped up on
the side to make sure you go to gamespot
com and check that out we will see you
next week tuesday 2 p.m. pacific right
here on guess what I crown good back